- You are going to learn
about positive communication
skills for leaders.
I'm here with my good friend
and co-author, Julien Mirivel,
and we're gonna talk to
you all about some content
from our recent book, also called,
"Positive Communication for Leaders".
We wrote this book and we're
making this video series,
because now more than ever,
leaders need to be able to
connect with their followers,
their employees, to build relationships,
and help cultivate a team
that's cohesive and effective.
In fact, we're doing a seven-part series.
This is video number one,
where we're gonna break down
all of the behaviors in this
model of positive communication
that Julien came up
with several years back,
and we've now built a book around it
on leadership and this video series,
so let's get right into it.
Julien, what is a positive leader?
- Well, you know, positive
leadership is all about dreaming
about the people who inspire us,
and we want people who
are watching this video
to feel it, too, so try to
do this exercise with us.
Think about one of the
most inspirational leaders
that you have worked with in
your own professional career.
Try to identify someone specific,
somebody who made a
real positive difference
in the workplace for you.
What was it like to work for them?
What emotions did they bring out of you?
And what did they specifically
do to make you feel this way?
What are the aspect of their leadership
that really encouraged excellence in you,
but maybe also other people around you?
And if you can think of specific habits,
maybe personality traits,
but more importantly, core
behaviors, what they did,
then perhaps you can identify
what we're going to be
describing in these seven videos.
- And we'd actually like you
to pause the video right now.
If you don't have
someone specific in mind,
it's really important that you think
of a specific inspirational leader
who you've worked directly with
in the past in one way or another.
The goal, of course, is
not to just talk about
this inspirational leader in your life,
but to help you become one, too.
- We don't know what you wrote down.
We don't know who you're thinking about.
We don't know, maybe not
even know that person,
but we believe that
there are some elements
of inspirational leadership
that transcends all leaders
who are doing this way and all cultures.
You know, we've tested this now,
this question in the
United States and Canada,
but also, in Saudi Arabia and Costa Rica,
a number of other cultures.
And we found that no matter where we go,
inspirational leaders
have common qualities
no matter where we live and work.
So often those individuals are leaders
who make us feel valued, and
they make us feel respected.
These leaders are people
who create an environment,
where we feel like we can thrive,
where we really empowered,
and obviously, they create
a great place to work,
an environment that's challenging,
but that's also encouraging
and safe for all.
In short, they are what Alex and I
would call a positive leader.
They make choices every day
about how to be and how to act,
and those actions end up creating
an extraordinary workplace.
And what we wanna show you
is how you can do that, too.
- So what Julien and I
are doing in this series
is we're looking at six
key communication behaviors
for leaders, and we're
gonna make a follow-up video
for each of those six behaviors,
where we drill down deeply.
Right now, we're going
to give you an overview
of these six behaviors,
so you get an overview of the overall
positive communication
model that Julien created,
and Julien's gonna start us off.
- The first behavior of positive
communication is greeting.
Greet to create human contact.
The act of greeting,
we know acknowledges
that other people exist,
and it naturally moves us
in the direction of others.
And so as a leader, Alex
and I really encourage
great leaders to create lots
of connections with people,
and learn how to repair relationships
when they're not doing well.
When you choose to greet other people,
you also choose to
create great connections
and build relationships.
- The second behavior is asking questions.
Ask questions to discover the unknown.
The questions you ask
shape the responses you get
in conversations with other people.
And as a leader, you
need to place yourself
in a position of discovery,
so that you can learn
about your followers' needs
and interests and wants and their world,
so that you, as a leader, can adapt
and enter their world more successfully.
You can lead essentially
through asking better questions.
That's a real concept that
is hard to understand,
because most leaders wanna
talk at their people,
and there's a time and a place for that.
But we want to coach you to
learn how to ask questions,
to develop relationships and
get to know people better.
- Third, positive
leaders give compliments.
They use positive
communication to affect others.
Complimenting others
affects their sense of self.
We believe that what you say and do
shapes not just who you are
and who other people are,
but also fundamentally
shape who they become.
And so as a leader, you can
use the power of communication
to affect others in a positive direction.
And the behavior we want
people thinking about
is complimenting and the
ability to give specific,
meaningful feedback to build people up,
and strengthen the people
you work with along the way.
- Fourth is disclosure.
Disclose more to deepen
your relationships.
Now, disclosure happens
anytime you reveal anything
about yourself to other people.
As a leader, that means
talking about who you are,
maybe even outside of work a little bit.
It's about revealing your opinions,
stories about your background.
It's about telling
people your expectations,
so they don't have to read your mind.
It's about sharing gratitude
and expressing that gratitude,
because people may not realize
how grateful you are for them.
Now, when you disclose, it
can feel a little vulnerable.
And when we get into the
specific video about disclosure,
we'll address that.
But anytime you are disclosing
and putting yourself out there,
you're starting to
strengthen the relationships
that you've begun forming earlier.
- The fifth behavior of
positive communication
is encouraging.
Encourage your people to give support.
Every workplace is going
to face challenges.
Every employee will have
moments of great times,
a moment of really difficult time.
And what great leadership
is all about is finding ways
of supporting the people
around you to succeed.
Leadership is both managing crisis,
but also finding ways to motivate
and encouraging employees
at the right moment and at the right time.
When you choose to
communicate effectively,
what you're doing is you're
using communication as a gift,
and then you have the ability
to provide the support
that people need to succeed,
and we'll show you how.
- The sixth part of
this model is listening.
Improve how you listen
to transcend differences.
Now, no comprehensive model
would be complete without listening.
On a personal level, you need
to practice what we call,
deep listening to your
followers and your employees,
so you can understand their needs.
Those followers need to be heard
and you, as a leader,
have that responsibility.
That means, of course,
removing distractions,
and really 100% being all in
focused on your listening.
When you listen deeply like
that, you will transcend
the perceived differences
between you and others
and between and among your followers.
And that will help create more team unity,
and bring people together
to create cohesiveness
in your organization's culture.
You find common ground,
and you begin to understand
how you can work together.
Those are the six behaviors.
That's an overview taken together,
the six behaviors form
the model or the wheel
of positive communication for leaders.
And as we asked earlier,
how many of these behaviors
did that inspirational leader
that you thought of do?
If you think about how they come across,
how they communicate with you
and other people around them,
we're wondering how
many of the six they do.
It shows you how important these are.
And over the next several
weeks, as I mentioned,
we're gonna be putting
out six more videos,
one on each of these six behaviors
that are gonna drill down more deeply,
and coach you through
exactly how to do them,
when to do them, even give you some good
starter sentences and samples,
so you can see exactly
how you can apply them.
We're also putting out a free email class,
a mini email class, a series
of nine emails that echo
what you're gonna be learning
in this video series.
And, of course, you can
find our book on Amazon
"Positive Communication for Leaders".
We'll put links to all of that
in the expandable description
below the video.
- We'd love to hear how you
would answer the question
we pose at the opening of the video,
who is the most inspirational
leader who has affected you?
Can you please put that
in the common section?
What emotions did they bring out of you?
What did they specifically
do to make you feel that way?
And what aspect of their leadership style
encourage excellence in you?
Leadership is about influencing others.
And what we're really going
to show you is how to use
the power of positive communication
to inspire others effectively.
Leaders like you can
be powerful role models
to motivate others.
- Be sure you tune in for the next video,
where we're gonna show
you how to do greetings
much more effectively, and show
you how powerful that can be
in starting conversations
and starting relationships.
Thanks for tuning in.
We look forward to reading
your comments below.
Until next time, God bless, see you soon.
(upbeat music)
You are going to learn how
to greet people effectively
in conversations.
Good greetings are the fundamental
opening of every social
and even professional conversation.
Our focus is gonna be on
professional settings,
but you can use good greetings
in any interaction in your life,
and I'm here with Dr. Julien Mirivel.
We co-authored a book together called
"Positive Communication for Leaders".
It's built around a six-part model
that Julien created years ago,
and it's the backbone of this
video series and our book.
In fact, this is video number two
in a series of seven videos
that we're putting out
over the next several weeks.
We hope you stick around for all of it.
Today, we're focusing on
greeting people with intention
and all the power that comes
from opening conversations
on the right foot like that.
So first, why are intentional
greetings so important?
- So Alex, greetings are important,
because they at the heart
of human connection.
Interactions that start with simple things
like good morning, it's good to see you,
or even an how are you,
matters more in the world
of leadership than we think.
When you greet other people,
you literally acknowledge their existence.
A greeting says, "I see you,
I know that you're there."
And more importantly, it
cues to the other person,
I want to connect with you.
It's me moving in the direction of others.
So while greeting is a small behavior,
we know that it can have
an outsize big impact,
because the ultimate goal
of positive communication
is to create "high quality connections",
a word developed by Jane Dutton,
a professor emerita at the business school
at the University of Michigan.
And these are short, positive
interactions that have a range
of beneficial outcomes for
both people and their cultures.
Greeting is moving in the
direction of other people,
and making it possible to start
those high quality connections.
- Now, if you think
greetings are too easy,
too simple to study and practice,
I'd like to say more about how
a good greeting is much more
than simply saying hello.
A greeting serves a number of functions,
especially in a professional setting.
So greetings open up a
sequence of communication
between two people.
Someone has to make the first move.
And if you've ever been
sitting there in a room,
where people haven't greeted each other
and got to know each other,
it can be very difficult to
feel comfortable around them,
because they're unfamiliar.
But a greeting starts the
communication sequence.
Greetings also both
define and affirm people
and relationships.
Moving in to say hello, when you do that,
you're demonstrating that
you're open, approachable,
you're willing to engage, that
you care about other people.
This is one of the
reasons why when employees
at the lower levels of
the pyramids, so to speak,
feel so honored and cared for,
when a high status leader
in the organization
actually greets them, knows
their name, says hello,
because it says to the
employee, the follower,
"You matter, I care about you enough
to pause for a minute and greet you."
And greetings, also, third,
help you build a bridge to
achieve a specific purpose.
So beyond the social connections,
when you're in the workplace,
you greet someone as just the
beginning, and it's understood
that there's probably
some task collaboration
that's going to follow that greeting.
And you can't get to the task
until you have a good
opening to the conversation.
So a greeting just sets the
stage, it's just the beginning.
But what happens, Julien,
if we don't greet each
other with intention?
Let's look at the other side of the coin.
- So, you know, Alex, when
we don't greet each other
with intentionality,
first, what happens is the
relationship is hurt, right?
Without communication,
there is no relationship.
Without greeting, there's
no quality connection.
But if we don't pay
attention to these details,
interaction can quickly feel awkward.
I'm sure you've been in a situation,
where you say hello to somebody
and the other person doesn't
respond, and suddenly,
you feel, wow, what just took place here?
You know, I feel totally alone
and isolated from this encounter.
A second thing that happens
is it feels disrespectful, right?
So if we're walking down the hallway
and our boss is not even seeing us,
is not even acknowledging us,
we feel disrespected in some form.
So being attentive to
that detail really matters
in the world of leadership.
And then finally, we have not caring.
You know, most of us,
we want to be valued.
We want to be loved in some
way, and greeting is the way,
it's a small way of showing to people,
"Hey, I care about you.
I wanna see how you're doing."
And when we pay attention to it,
we can start to transform where
the relationships all about.
Greetings, help us connect
with each other relationally,
and they create a stage
for working together
even more effectively.
- Now, you probably know a
good greeting when you see it,
but we're gonna spell it out for you,
so that you can do it more
consistently and reliably.
There are four elements of a
good greeting, here they are.
First, it has to be authentic.
You have to actually
care about other people.
If you just give a default
automatic greeting,
they're gonna feel that it
doesn't come across as genuine,
so you have to muster up your
actual care for other people
when you greet them.
And then it'll feel more authentic,
and you'll form a little connection.
Second, you have to do something verbal.
You have to say, hello, hey,
how you doing, good morning,
how was your weekend?
Verbalize your greeting,
don't just nod at them.
But third, nonverbal is also important.
You nod, you make eye contact,
you pause and orient you
shoulders toward the other person.
And four, be patient.
Don't rush your greeting.
You have to take that
extra couple of seconds
to greet them effectively.
We believe that greetings
are an literal leadership behavior,
because as we wrote in our book,
"Positive Communication for Leaders",
"It's a leader's responsibility
to initiate connection
with their people."
The leader, in other words, sets the tone.
So Julien, tell us about your example
you were sharing with me the other day.
- Well, you know, I just
had a wonderful visit
with a Japanese executive.
I was in Costa Rica, and
we just found each other
really at a restaurant.
And we ended up kind
of talking and engaging
in conversation.
And as I got to know him,
he shared his whole leadership story.
And really, it was one of sadness.
He realized that he was isolated.
He realized that he was not treating
his people particularly well.
In fact, he said, "You
know, for most of my career,
when I would go to the office,
I would walk straight through the hallway.
I wouldn't even say hi to people.
And I would go to my desk,
and straight to my PC."
And even when people went
to see him in his office,
he'd be working away
typing in the computer.
And somebody would come and he
would say, "Okay, thank you."
Barely make eye contact and barely engage.
And he said, as a result of that approach,
he lost a lot of respect.
He lost a sense of connection to people
and it had consequences.
And he said, "Now, I'm
having a paradigm shift.
I realize I cannot just be
a boss talking to objects.
I have to be a leader
from person to person."
And he started to implement
some of what we're describing,
which is moving towards others,
and asking how they're doing,
and checking in with colleagues.
And when people come into the office,
then you respond positively
to the first part of the greeting.
And he noticed that those
relationships started to grow.
And not only that,
but his leadership
approach grew as a result.
And his influence, of course.
- Wonderful, so here is your challenge,
your application for this video,
anybody watching, so you
can get on the right path.
First, make a list of two
people in your organization
that you either don't know but you wanna,
or that you know you need
to connect with more.
Next, give each person a call
or a quick visit in person.
You can do this on email if you must,
but we really think
face-to-face or a phone call
is the best way to start
forming a real connection.
Next, give them your best
greeting, and simply tell them
that you wanted to check in
and see how they were doing.
Next, make a little bit of small talk,
and then see where the
interaction takes you.
And at the end of the conversation,
there may be a need to follow up
and you can make a plan
to follow up later.
That's your challenge for this video.
Start greeting people
well, do it with intention,
and start with two people who
you can identify specifically.
So this is the second video
in a series of seven videos
on positive communication.
For leaders, we invite you
to watch all seven videos.
We're gonna put links to all of them
once they're all posted
in the description below,
along with a free email class series
that you can sign up for
that mirrors or echoes
and reinforces what we're
talking about in the videos.
And, of course, you can pick up a copy
of the book on Amazon if you'd like.
Links to all of that is in the
description below the video.
So we'll see you in the next video,
where we're gonna talk
about the importance
of asking questions, a
critical leadership behavior.
We look forward to reading your comments
in the comment section below.
Until next time, thanks.
God bless you, and we will see you soon.
(upbeat music)
Today, you're going to learn how to ask
better questions in conversations.
And I'm here with my good
friend, Dr. Julien Mirivel.
We recently wrote a book together
called, "Positive
Communication for Leaders".
It's built around a six-part model
that Julien created years ago,
and we've recently wrote
this book around it.
And we're also doing a
video series around it.
This is video number three
in a seven-part series
on each of the individual
behaviors in that model.
And we're gonna get right to it today
about how to ask good questions.
So your first step as a leader
is to commit to asking more questions.
Julien, why should we ask more questions?
- Well, you know, for
leaders asking questions
is so important.
It immediately puts you in
a position of discovery.
And as leaders, we just
tend to get into the habit
of just telling people what to do.
We give lots of directives,
and we acknowledge that
there's a time and a place
for sharing information in that way.
But what makes questions so powerful
and so much more effective
is that they engage people,
and they get the leaders to be placed
in a position of discovery.
And as a leader, questions
immediately accomplish that goal,
and help you really lead to
concrete positive outcomes.
Here's some facts that
Alex and I really like.
You know, one of them is this.
Only 6% of all acts of communication
are actually questions.
But 60% of what we say
is actually in response to a question.
In other words, questions are
exponentially more engaging
than just making statements.
And research shows that
once we ask a question,
our minds almost entirely
focus on trying to answer it.
So what makes questions powerful, Alex,
is that when you ask a question,
you set in motion what
the next turn of talk
is going to be about, what
other people are going to say,
and that's gonna shape what
the interaction is all about.
Good questions will give
followers and colleagues
an opportunity to voice their opinions,
but it's also gonna
show them that you care
about their views and about them as people
- Asking questions is a
fundamental leadership behavior.
In fact, there are lots of
benefits to asking questions
versus simply making statements.
In fact, the benefits are
really hard to believe.
So simply by asking more questions,
here's what you benefit from.
Individuals who ask
questions and listen deeply
are more likely to be
perceived as leaders.
Leaders who ask meaningful
questions for input
are seen by others as
increasing effectiveness.
Leaders who ask meaningful
and respectful questions
create more encouraging
work relationships.
And leaders who ask good questions
successfully motivate their employees.
So given all of these
benefits, we're asking you,
start asking more questions
in the next 24 hours
after watching this video.
And the more questions you ask,
the more repetitions you'll get,
and you will get better at
this the more you do it.
So the second tip, in addition
to asking more questions
is to improve the quality
of the questions you ask.
Julien, how can we do that?
How can we ask better questions?
- So what we show in the book
and what we really want you
to learn in today's video is
how to flip your questions,
to move from asking close-ended questions,
to asking open-ended questions.
And there's a big difference.
Open-ended questions typically start
with words like how, what, or why.
Close-ended questions tend
to start with words like,
are you, will you, did you.
And you'll notice that
closed-end questions
control and narrow the interaction
versus open-ended questions,
which kind of given an
expansiveness, right?
A breadth of answers.
Let me give you a scenario.
So you come to work on a Monday morning,
you go see a colleague, and you ask,
"Did you have a fun this weekend?"
And the person may say,
"Yeah, how about you?"
And you notice that's
a close-ended question,
did you have fun this weekend,
and the answer you got is very short.
In fact, you've learned
nothing about your colleague,
what they enjoy doing, or
even about their weekends.
Close-ended questions can be
acceptable as a starting point,
but you notice that for leaders,
they need to learn to
ask open-ended questions,
'cause that's where the connection is,
and that's where you can
learn from other people.
So take the same situation,
it's a Monday morning,
you go to work to see a colleague.
What if instead of asking,
did you have a fun weekend,
you flip the question,
and just ask, "What did
you do this weekend?"
And you'll notice the person may respond
with something like this, "Oh,
I did all sorts of things.
You know, I went to the beach
on Saturday with my family,
then on Sunday, we cooked
a great meal together."
And they may share even more information.
And the more they share,
the more you'll learn.
And the more you'll learn,
the more you'll have understanding,
and that's what you want as a leader.
- Open-ended questions
virtually always lead
to a more robust conversation
than close-ended questions.
So here's some sample open-ended questions
that you can ask your followers.
Here are the questions
you might ask to discover
what your followers think, for example,
"What is your opinion on this?"
"How do you feel about X?"
"What do you see as the next steps?"
Here's some other samples
you can ask your followers
if you wanna discover
more about them outside
of their role at work.
You could ask, "Tell me your story."
"What are some of your personal
and professional goals?"
"Who are your role models?"
"When do you feel truly
energized and engaged at work?"
I recently asked one of these questions
when I was out to dinner with Julien.
We were both presenting to
a client in another city,
and the client took us out to dinner
the night before our presentation,
and after we ordered our food,
we had some time to talk.
And I simply asked each of our
hosts, "Tell me your story."
And they said, "Well, what
do you mean, what story?"
And I said, "Your whole life story."
And for the next 45 minutes to an hour,
the four of us went around,
and basically told our life story,
short versions of our life story.
In fact, one of the people
went back about 400 years
to when their ancestors first
arrived in the United States.
And you could feel as
the conversation went on,
we were discovering the
unknown about each other
and our relationship was
deepening with each talking turn.
It was really a fantastic conversation
and the person the next day mentioned
what a powerful interaction it was.
So Julien, why don't you tell us about
the next steps for this video?
- Yeah, we'd like you to
take a few next steps,
and the first one is if you have used
the great open-ended questions
that has worked for you,
put it in the comments below,
so we can all learn from each other,
and have lots of examples of
great open-ended questions
to open up our conversations with others.
But the second thing we would
like you to do as a next step
is to commit to asking more
questions, better questions,
and more open questions
in the next 24 hours.
We want you to feel and see the difference
if you move from asking
close-ended questions
to asking open-ended questions
in your interactions.
So specifically, what we'd like you to do
is go meet with a follower, or
a colleague, or an employee,
and ask them three meaningful
open-ended questions
to position yourself
in a mode of discovery.
Make this whole intention
about getting to know them,
and getting to understand
their perspective
and their worldview.
And you'll notice that when you do that,
something really magical
happens in the interaction.
As we say in our book,
"It's up to leaders to position themselves
to ask better questions
and to discover what people have to say."
And when you do that,
you're gonna experience
something completely different
in the realm of your relationships,
both even at work and at home.
- This is the third video in this series
of seven for communication
for positive leaders.
We encourage you to stick
with the entire series.
We're gonna post all of the videos
once they're all posted out there
in the expandable
description below the video.
You can also sign up for
the free mini email class
that mirrors what we're going
through in these videos.
And, of course, you can pick up a copy
of our new book at Amazon.
Links to all of that are
in the description below.
We look forward to reading your comments,
and in the next video, we're gonna work
on how to give compliments,
another key behavior for positive leaders.
We'll see you then, bye-Bye.
(upbeat music)
Today, you're going to learn
how to give positive feedback,
specifically how to give
genuine compliments.
This works in a workplace situation,
but works really in any
kind of relationship.
And we are in video number
four in a seven-part series.
I'm here with my good
friend, Dr. Julien Mirivel.
We co-wrote a book together
called, "Positive
Communication for Leaders".
And this video series
is based upon that book,
which is based upon a model
of positive communication
that Julien developed several years back.
In part, leadership is about
creating an environment
in which people feel valued,
respected, and engaged.
And one of the best ways to create that
is by giving more positive feedback.
Our approach in this video is to show you
how to give genuine compliments,
to build relationships,
and enhance employee and
organizational performance.
Complimenting is one of
the six key behaviors
in Julien's positive
model of communication.
- In the model of positive communication,
we argue that complimenting
affects people's sense of self.
It affects not just who
they are in the moment,
their identity, but it
more importantly impacts
who they're going to become.
Complimenting is a powerful
form of giving positive feedback
because one, it's the most direct way
of telling another person who
they are and how we see them.
It also identifies
specifically good performance
or great performance, and then
it shapes the other person,
their sense of self, their identities.
Positive feedback,
complimenting, and recognition
drive toward lots of benefits for leaders,
many of which we mention in the book.
Consider several facts, from
the most up-to-date research
we have on this topic.
The most compelling driver
of an employee's performance
is the quality of the
relationship that they have
with their immediate supervisor.
Focusing on strength is
going to improve performance,
whereas, focusing on weaknesses,
which is going to undermine performance.
And then finally, employees
consider recognition
for a job well done, respectful treatment,
and coaching and feedback
more important than pay
across the board.
- Let's make this even
more personal right now.
Take a moment to reflect on
your experience as an employee,
some kind of follower.
When you've been in that
role, what is one compliment
you've received in your
professional career
that has meant a great deal to you?
Who gave you this compliment,
and how did it affect you
in the short term and the long term?
And you may even wanna
take a moment to write down
exactly what was said,
so you can see the words,
see the message.
You may notice that as you remember this,
and write it down, and
bring it to mind right now,
It can start to create some
of the positive feelings
that you felt at the time.
- Let's give your own illustration.
Here's a compliment that I received
that made a very positive impact on me
and my professional development.
Years ago, when I was a young
professor at the university,
on a Friday afternoon around four o'clock,
I received a phone call.
I picked up the phone,
and I said, "Hi, this is Julien Mirivel.
How can I help you?"
On the other hand was David Belcher,
who was at the time, the
provost of the university,
the chief academic officer,
and he's giving me a call.
He says, "You know Julien, I'm
about to become chancellor,
and I'm moving and transitioning
to a new university,
but I wanted to make a
few phone calls to people
I really believe in on campus.
And I want you to know that
you're an extraordinary teacher,
an extraordinary scholar,
and you are going to be an amazing leader
for this institution.
I cannot wait to see what you're gonna do
in the next 10 years."
That compliment really impacted me,
not just in that moment
but for years to come.
- And you can see how a sincere compliment
from David Belcher influenced Julien.
He remembers it to this day.
It wasn't just shaping
how he felt in the moment,
it shaped how he saw himself
moving forward in the future.
And in the same way, now
imagine the kind of impact
you can have by giving sincere
compliments to the followers
and employees who you work with.
The bottom line of this
video is we want you to start
giving more compliments
to the people around you.
Look for ways to reach out,
and give them some positive
feedback like that.
So what can you give compliments about?
Let's give it even more
hands-on for you right now.
Start by focusing on two key areas,
where people generally want
to feel those compliments come their way.
The first is that we all have a need
to be seen by others as competent.
The second is, we need
to feel appreciated,
liked, and valued.
So those are two areas that you can give
other people compliments.
So right now, think of an actual person
in your professional life.
Reflect on when you have
seen them at their best
in terms of what they
might be demonstrating
their competence for.
So maybe you saw them, for example,
doing a great presentation.
Perhaps, you saw them handle
a difficult situation well
during a meeting.
Now, in the same way,
think about a compliment
that you may communicate to them
that shows that you like
them and appreciate them.
Now, keep in mind, you have to
give appropriate compliments.
This is a workplace setting after all.
We don't recommend, for example,
you give other people compliments
about their appearance.
That can often come off the wrong way,
but you can give them
compliments about how you feel
about them in terms of
your appreciate them
and you like them.
For example, Julien just
the other day sent me a text
about how much he enjoys working
on this video series together
and on our book together
that we collaborated
on for a couple years.
He's really good at that.
So the key to these
compliments is being sincere.
This can't be calculated
like you're doing it
to get something from them.
Genuine compliments
are the most direct way
to give positive feedback to people,
and shape how they see themselves.
- Let's take some action today.
Step one, take a minute to
identify one person you work with
that could really benefit
from a compliment.
This person could be a peer, a supervisor,
or simply a subordinate,
somebody who you work with every day.
Step two, consider
these questions to draft
your very own meaningful compliment.
When have you seen this
person at their best?
When have you recently seen
this person do something special
or even make an important contribution?
And more importantly,
you can ask what strength
do you see in them on a consistent basis?
Once you've answered these questions,
you move on to step three.
You craft your compliment.
When drafting your compliment,
make sure to identify a specific example
of when you saw the
person do something great,
and explain how what they did
has led to positive outcome
on the basis of their strength.
Let me share with you a compliment
that I've been drafting for Alex,
who's really been influential
in our ability to write the book,
but also make great progress
in our own personal
and professional lives.
Working with you, Alex,
is an absolute highlight
of my career.
You're kind, you're
generous, you're ethical,
and you're so energizing
in everything that you do.
I'm inspired by what you
are doing and who you are
as a person and a professional every day.
And more importantly, you've
helped to make the book
that we wrote together,
concrete and practical,
and you always kept refining
it until it was something
that we were both really proud of.
In short, I'm thankful for our friendship,
and I'm thankful for your leadership.
Thanks, my friend.
- Thank you.
I don't wanna pause for too long here,
'cause we're in the middle of a video,
but I really appreciate that, Julien.
- So once you've crafted your compliment,
you have to move to step four,
because we have to let
people know how we feel,
and that's step four.
Step four is deliver your compliment.
Research shows that the most
meaningful way of delivering
a compliment is to do it in person,
because it's the most memorable.
If you cannot do that,
if that's not possible,
feel free to express your compliment
maybe in a personal written note.
Either way, and as we explain in the book,
the most important part of complimenting
is communicating it.
- Now, the reason we're
emphasizing that last point
is because here's an interesting fact.
Professionals often don't
compliment their people
even when they think
positively about them,
and they don't do it for three reasons.
The first reason is they
think positive thoughts,
but don't bother to say them out loud.
Second reason is they
expect that the interaction
will be awkward when they express it.
And the third is they simply don't think
that it's important enough
to acknowledge others aloud.
In other words, you personally
may have to push yourself
to compliment others.
In a study, only 50% of the participants
who actually prepared a written compliment
followed through and delivered it,
and we hope that you are in that 50%.
So we're encouraging you to
actually deliver the compliment
and begin to give more compliments
as a result of watching this video.
People don't have access
merely to what you think
and how you feel.
They can't see that.
They only have access
to what you actually do
and actually say aloud.
And that's why communicating
the compliment is so important.
So make sure you're in that
top 50% who communicate it.
- As a leader, you need to
use every opportunity you have
to strengthen the people you
work with, to build them up,
and prepare them for their future.
And we hope that using what
you're learning in this video,
you can apply this principle,
and seize those opportunities
at every moment.
- This is the fourth video in a series
of seven that we're making that break down
all of these skills in the book
on "Positive Communication for Leaders"
that you can check out on Amazon.
Also, there's a free
nine-day mini email class
that you can sign up for.
We'll put links to that,
and please feel free to
leave comments below.
We look forward to reading them.
In the next video, we go into
the topic of self-disclosure
for leaders in the workplace,
which is a really challenging one.
We hope you tune in for that.
Until then, thanks, God bless.
We'll see you soon.
(upbeat music)
Today, you're going to
learn how to be more open
in the workplace through self-disclosure.
Now, the focus here in the video
is about professional
settings, but self-disclosure
can help deepen any relationship.
And I'm here with my good
friend and co-author,
Dr. Julien Mirivel.
Julien and I wrote a book together
called "Positive
Communication for Leaders".
It's the foundation of this video series.
We're in video number
five of seven videos.
Self-disclosure is one of the key
six communication behaviors in our book,
and it's a really important tool
that should be in every leader's toolbox.
And we'll put a link to the
book, the description below,
as well as a link to the mini email class
that you can sign up for.
In our experience,
self-disclosure is the behavior
and the positive communication model
with which most people
are least comfortable.
- In the model of positive communication,
we propose that when
leaders choose to disclose,
they naturally deepen the relationships
that they have with other people.
We know today that 52% of CEOs
feel lonely in their roles.
We know from reports across the world now
that people feel generally
lonely in the workplace,
approximately one in four adults does so.
And leadership positions in
general within organizations
often do not foster the
kind of work environments,
where friendship and social
intimacy are possible.
And the only way out of
that loneliness is to learn
to use the power of positive communication
to connect more deeply with people.
And disclosure is the
secret sauce for that goal.
It's an important leadership behavior,
because disclosure
deepens your relationships
and your connections with other people.
- So first, let's talk about
what disclosure is and is not.
At a basic level, disclosure
is about revealing aspects
about yourself, information about yourself
that people would not
know unless you told them.
Just the other day, for example,
a colleague of mine shared
some of her long-term
professional goals with me
that I would not have known
unless she talked about them.
In the same way, even in
professional settings,
disclosure can mean telling people about
what you did over the weekend,
talking about your family,
if you're comfortable with that,
or sharing a bit about
your hobbies and interests
outside of work.
Disclosure really is about an endless list
of potential activities or
information that you might share
that show who you are, show
how you think, how you feel,
and let other people get to know you.
- Ideally, for relationships
to be deepened,
disclosure needs to include
certain key features.
It must be authentic and genuine.
It has to be truthful and honest,
and it needs to be spontaneous
rather than strategic or calculated.
And more importantly,
it has to be personal.
When we disclose with these features,
we get to know each other
as whole human beings,
find common ground, and
learn to trust each other.
- So here's what disclosure is not.
In contrast to that list of positives,
disclosure is not about airing
all of your dirty laundry,
or getting too personal too fast,
or telling other people information
that's really not suitable
for the workplace.
Additionally, we'd like to
be clear here that disclosure
is not a superficial tactic that you use
to get something from
somebody or to close a sale.
You're not relating to
people in that strategic way.
We assume that you genuinely value people,
and have their best interest
in mind when you're disclosing.
And naturally, you must
use your best judgment
anytime you're disclosing,
and adapt any advice we're
giving you to your situation
and your personality.
Second, let's talk about
how you can begin disclosing
in helpful ways at work.
- The easiest way to get started
is to learn to tell your story.
Here are a couple ways.
One is to share information
about your own personal
and professional journey.
In most situations, the leader in the room
has been through similar
experiences in the past,
and telling others about the ups and downs
of our experiences and your
experiences can be a great way
to bond with other people.
We know this may seem
straightforward, but the question is,
are you doing it yet?
After this video, we hope you
do, because sharing your story
has lots and lots of
benefits for connection.
For example, in healthcare settings,
research has shown that doctors
who reveal their own
experiences to patients
improve not only patient satisfaction,
but their adherence to
treatment and the likelihood
that they would pursue legal
action and a bad scenario.
In the realm of education,
we know that teachers
who share their experiences with students,
whether that's their academic hardships,
or even stories about their lives,
not only impact student satisfaction,
but it literally improves
students' learning.
Sharing your stories at the heart
of how to create more trust
and better working
relationships with people.
And if sharing your story
makes you a little bit anxious,
remember that you are the decider.
You can decide what to
share and when not to share,
and you can always use your best judgment.
- Now, here's our pro tip on that topic,
disclose a little bit and see
how it goes, test this out.
So you reveal a little bit
of personal information,
and see how the other person responds.
If it goes well, then you
reveal a little bit more,
over time, and at your
own level of comfort.
So here's another way to self-disclose.
You can share some of your foibles,
and I'll explain what
that means in a moment.
So this is gonna take a little courage.
We're not used to talking
about our weaknesses,
but consider disclosing some
of your small shortcomings
or small weaknesses.
People can really relate to this.
In our book, we draw on the
writings of Allen Weiner.
He's a fellow speaker,
author, and consultant,
and he makes a habit out of talking about
his small weaknesses or
foibles with his employees,
but even really high
level executive clients
that he works with in
Fortune 500 companies.
- "A foible is a small weakness.
When I talk about mine,
people talk about theirs.
Sometimes, that helps
us make a connection.
I think I've surprised a lot
of people by my willingness
to share a weakness, and it's
helped them open up to me.
The more 'unsuitable'
my weakness to a point,
the more I have invited such a connection.
And most of the time the
person I've been talking with
[about my Weakness] will say,
'Don't be so hard on yourself.
I can get you one better.'"
Drawing on this example,
we know that talking
about our small weaknesses
can humanize you,
and it's going to make you
more approachable as a leader.
It opens up the door for
others to do the same,
because it liberates other people
to hear you speak
genuinely about yourself.
- And third, expect other
people to reciprocate.
The most likely result
of your self-disclosure
is that other people will do the same.
In the field of communication,
we call this reciprocity.
When you share information about yourself,
the most likely result is
people will start to disclose
a similar type of information
from their own lives.
In our presentations, we talk
about this as a magic wand.
Disclosure is the closest
thing we have to a magic wand
in terms of a concept in communication.
When you disclose other people almost
automatically reciprocate,
and you've probably felt
this dynamic in conversations
with other people, and it creates
a real bonding experience.
You can feel the relationship develop.
It's almost like giving each other
small holiday exchange gifts.
You can feel your relationship bond
over those disclosures and those gifts.
And in fact, one of the ways we do this
in our live presentations, is
we talk about ourselves a lot
to help us get to know the
audience and vice versa.
But one of the ways we do it
is to show pictures of my two dogs.
That's something for my personal life,
it has nothing to do with work,
and I put them up on the screen,
and I tell a quick story about them,
and we now stop our presentations
and give everybody there
the opportunity to share
pictures of their dogs, as well.
Because when I self-disclose
like a magic wand,
they wanna reciprocate and
share about their own pets,
and they do that with
the people around them.
And it's so effective at getting
people to bond and converse
that we actually have to put a stop to it
after a couple of minutes.
The bottom line is this
disclosure deepens relationships
and connections with others,
and that's why we consider it
one of the most important
positive communication behaviors.
- Your next steps are simple.
In the next 24 hours, apply these steps.
Use any opportunity you have
to tell more of your personal
or professional story whenever
it fits the situation.
If you're feeling
courageous, share a foible,
a small weakness, so
that people can connect
with the real you.
And more importantly, if
you hear someone disclose,
remember, that that's
the magic of disclosure,
that you can reciprocate and
share your very own story.
- This is video number five
in this series of seven videos
on positive communication for leaders.
We invite you to sign up
for the free nine-day mini email class
that echoes everything in here.
And when these are all
done, we're gonna post them
in links in the description
below the video.
And, of course, you can always
check out our book on Amazon.
So we'll see you in the next video
when we're gonna talk about the importance
of encouraging other people
when they face difficult situations.
We look forward to reading
all your comments below.
Until next time, thanks, God
bless, we'll see you soon.
(upbeat music)
Encouraging your people is part
of your leadership responsibilities,
and oh, boy, do we need
encouragement today?
And you're gonna learn how
to do that in this video.
I'm here with my good
friend, Dr. Julien Mirivel.
We co-authored a book together called,
"Positive Communication for Leaders".
That's the basis of this
video series we're doing.
In fact, this is video number six
in a seven-part series that
follows along with the book.
If you'd like to, you can
check out that book on Amazon,
and you can also check out
our nine-day mini email class
that follows and reinforces
what we're talking about in these videos.
And today's topic is encouragement.
Encouragement is a key leadership behavior
in the model of communication
that Julien developed years back.
And today, you're gonna
learn how to create
extraordinary moments with your people
through the power of encouragement.
People need their leaders
to encourage them now
more than ever.
- In the wheel of positive communication,
we describe the power of
encouragement as the ability
to give people the support
they need to succeed.
When we encourage, we give social support.
Consider some statistics that
we bring out in the book.
For example, according to a
recent article by Jason Kanov
and his research team, "Employee's
grief cost US businesses
about $75 billion annually."
And job stress and burnout
have been estimated to cost
to industry hundreds
of billions of dollars.
Similarly, we know today that
employees feel very lonely.
In fact, a recent poll revealed
that 8 out of 10 employees,
that's 82%, say that they
feel lonely in the workplace.
- Now, on the flip side,
we know that a little
compassion goes a long way.
For example, when leaders demonstrate
a preference for compassion,
their followers are 25%
more engaged in their jobs,
20% more committed, and at
an 11% lower risk of burnout.
Leaders who show compassion
also personally benefit
as they experience a 30% increase
in their own sense of
wellbeing and happiness
in their lives.
In other words, your
encouragement, your compassion,
your support make a measurable difference
in everybody's lives.
- In short, all employees
and followers need to feel
that they're cared for, they
need to feel attended to,
but they also need to be reminded
of why we do the things we do.
So how can you, as a leader,
supply the power of positive communication
to support your employees and
transform ordinary moments
into what Alex and I see
as extraordinary ones?
And the short answer is this,
take every opportunity you have
to encourage your employees
with any of these easy and
practical three strategies,
plus a bonus one that we're
gonna share after those.
The first one is this, give
sincere and meaningful advice
to support your employees
in one-on-one moments.
I had a great boss once who years ago
was having lunch with me to mentor me.
And for a long time, I was a smoker.
And in that conversation,
give me some advice that stuck with me.
He said, "You know Jillian,
how you quit smoking,
don't you?"
And I said, "No, what
are you talking about?"
And he said, "If you really
want to quit smoking,
you have to learn to quit
one cigarette at a time."
And it took a while for this encouragement
and advice to sink in,
but about two weeks later,
I decided to quit smoking,
and I've been smoke-free
now for over 16 years.
One piece of advice made a huge difference
and encouraged me to do what
I wanted to do to begin with.
- And it certainly
remains a memorable moment
as you can see, because Julien
told me about it years ago,
and reminded me of it as
we were writing this book,
the second strategy is
to alleviate distress
by providing support.
So I used to be the chair
of my academic department.
I teach college full-time still.
And for about four years,
I was the chair or
supervisor of my department.
I was really burned out
at the end of that time.
But my new chair, my new supervisor,
was amazing at providing support.
He sensed that I was burned out.
He gave me an amazing teaching
schedule, really ideal,
so that I would have a
little more free time.
And he also delegated some
of the heavy responsibilities
that I had been carrying to
other people to rotate that,
so that other people could handle 'em
to alleviate my distress.
And fast forward to this
year, I feel refreshed,
and I'm having my best
teaching year I've had
in a long time, and he did
this by providing support.
He alleviated my distress,
and that was an incredibly supportive,
very practical way that he helped me.
- The third strategy is
to help your employees
refocus on their strength
after they have failed
or after they've encountered a setback.
With the book that we wrote,
Alex and I interviewed a
professional who told us a story
about a time where she had
made a big mistake at work.
So the first thing she did
is she called her boss,
and admitted to all the
things that had happened
as a result of some of
the actions that she took.
Her boss on the phone after listening
to all of her concerns
and solving the problems,
then told her this.
She said, "Analiese, you're
really good at what you do.
You are good at your job, and you care,
and you can overcome any
challenge, no problem."
That encouragement made a huge world
of difference in Analiese,
and helped her overcome the failure
that she had just encountered.
- These are all small,
but thoughtful behaviors
that you can do to take difficult moments,
and turn them into fond
and extraordinary memories,
just like the memories that we have.
So fourth, your bonus strategy
is the encouraging power
of your presence.
Simply being available,
simply being present,
and giving another person your time
is, sometimes, all that's needed,
and it may in fact be all that you can do.
Not every difficulty or discouragement
that someone's going
through can be something
that you can fix and do something about
on a practical level.
However, you can make a
difference just by being there
to offer your time,
attention, and support.
Sometimes, that's the biggest
difference that you can make,
simply to make yourself available,
and let them know that
you are there for them.
- Let's get practical.
Here's your challenge for this video.
Identify one employee or a colleague
who seems to be a little
disconnected from work,
maybe even disengaged from the mission.
Reach out to them personally,
and make some time to interact one-on-one.
Third step, make sure
to ask lots of questions
about their experiences at work,
and to listen as deeply as you can
to what they're going through.
When it's appropriate, then
use that time to your offer
one meaningful advice
or meaningful fitting
piece of encouragement.
- And remember, sometimes,
just your supportive
and encouraging presence
will be the very best thing
that you can offer someone
during times of difficulty.
Those are the kinds of memories
that they may carry with
them for a long time.
This is the sixth of seven
videos in this series
on positive communication for leaders.
As I mentioned, you can
sign up for the nine-day
free mini email class
that echoes the contents
and reinforces everything
we've been talking about.
And you can always check
out our book on Amazon.
We'll see you in the next video,
the final video in this series
on the importance of deep
listening for leaders.
We look forward to seeing you there,
and looking at your comments
in that section below the video.
Until then, see you soon, and God bless.
(upbeat music)
Listening skills are a critical
skill for every leader,
and you're going to learn how to improve
your listening skills today.
I'm here with my good
friend and co-author,
Dr. Julien Mirivel.
We wrote a book called "Positive
Communication for Leaders"
that this video series is based upon.
In fact, this is the seventh
and final video in this series.
You can go back and watch
the rest of the videos.
We'll put links to the entire series
in the description below the video.
And if you'd like to sign up
for the free mini email class
that echoes everything we're
talking about in this series,
you can do that, as well.
And by the way, I just
wanna take a moment here
at the end of this series.
If our names sound familiar,
you may recognize us from
our blockbuster movie series,
"Madagascar".
I am Alex the Lion.
Of course, he is the original King Julien.
Now, we're just joking, of course,
but our names really are very similar,
and we've had those names
before those characters.
And I actually do call Julien
the original King Julien,
for fun once in a while.
And I've been called many
times, Alex the Lion.
Anyway, back to our story,
we're going to talk about listening.
It's a key leadership behavior,
and Julien's going to
talk about this skill
from the perspective of his model
that he created on positive communication.
- When you choose to listen as a leader,
you are choosing to transcend
the perceived differences
that exist between you and other people.
Why is listening such an important
leadership behavior, Alex?
- But listening is an often overlooked,
and usually undervalued
communication skill.
It often doesn't look
like anything's happening,
but if you want to take
your leadership seriously,
then you have to work on your listening,
because the higher up leaders
go in any organization
the more time they spend listening.
In fact, as we show in our book,
executives spend twice
as much time listening
compared to the average employee.
And emerging leaders spend
more and more time listening
as they move up the ladder
in any kind of organization.
And people in all walks of life,
whether they're in an organization
or in their personal life,
love great listeners.
- But there are real
important practical benefits
to being a great listener.
Leaders who listen well and deeply,
get to know their people better.
They also can be more easily identifying
the emerging problems that are
taking place on the ground.
They have more input about solutions
that could be more effective
to solve real problems.
They also are really good
if you use listening,
you can resolve the problems
before they get bigger.
And more importantly, most of us,
we want to avoid hard
conversations, right?
Difficult moments.
If you can listen a
little bit more deeply,
you can avoid these hard talks,
because you're managing
problems all along the way.
For these reasons, it doesn't surprise us
that some of the best
listeners we've ever met
are leaders sitting at the top
of the organizational chart.
- So what does good listening look like,
sound like, and feel like?
Well, in our book, we use
the term "deep listening"
to indicate that
listening well goes beyond
superficial tactics like fake listening
to give people the impression
that you're listening when you're not.
For example, deep listeners
follow three key behaviors.
First, deep listeners are fully present
and completely in the moment.
Deep listeners put their phones away.
They reduce all distractions.
They literally lean their bodies in,
and they listen with their
eyes, not just their ears.
Deep listeners, for example,
are never looking over
your shoulder to see
who else might be a little
more interesting in the room.
And a fully present
listener makes you feel
like you're the most important person
in the world at that moment.
They're fully present,
and that is a choice.
For example, they say that Elvis Presley
made you feel like you were
the only person that existed
in the entire universe while
he was speaking to you.
He made you feel special.
And if the king of rock and roll
had the time to make people
feel that way, so can you.
- Deep listeners are also open.
You know, openness is
about welcoming new ideas,
perspectives, and approaches.
We know that remaining open is difficult,
but it does not mean
abandoning your point of view.
In fact, openness is all about maintaining
a really fine, delicate balance
between holding onto your own perspective,
and being profoundly open to
the perspective of others.
Openness is typically difficult
for people to develop,
because it involves our ability to accept
and welcome new information,
which may even contradict
our own thinking.
We interviewed a variety
of leaders for the book
that Alex and I wrote,
but one of them said this,
"Leaders, in general, are very stubborn.
They believe in something
and they keep on pushing
whether people agree or disagree."
But he added this important
piece of information.
He said, "But I have found
that listening deeply
always gives me a new perspective."
So gaining a fresh perspective,
even if one may not
fully change their view,
is obviously critical for leaders.
So as a leader, we
encourage you to remain open
to hearing new ideas,
to hearing new thoughts,
and constructs that
will help you innovate,
adapt, and hopefully thrive.
- The third behavior is that
deep listeners show empathy.
Put simply empathy is your
ability to put yourself
in the other person's shoes
to understand their world,
and to feel what they are
feeling in that moment.
Empathy usually involves pitching back
what you believe you have heard,
or asking a few follow-up
questions to make sure
you are understanding the other person's
point of view accurately.
So I'm gonna give you a few
straightforward examples
of how you might respond in the moment,
and we're gonna be really
straightforward here.
When good listeners respond,
they keep their responses low key.
For example, they may say things like,
"I hear you."
"Makes sense."
"I see what you mean."
Or even simply, "Hm."
You'll notice that these
replies are all very short.
Great listeners are not eager
to take their own big talking turn,
or to jump in with a
story to match your story.
They're entirely focused
on understanding you
and understanding your world.
As Stephen Covey might say,
"Great listeners listen to understand;
they don't listen to simply reply."
- Let's get actionable,
here is your challenge.
This is a simple action
step, but it takes commitment
and courage on your part
to execute this challenge.
In the next 24 hours,
strive to make listening
your dominant goal in any
conversation that you're having.
It's gonna be your purpose.
Use the tips that we've
shared in this video
to listen more effectively
and more deeply.
Remember that it's a part of your job.
Here's a quick summary.
Recognize that listening is
a leadership responsibility.
And deep listening means that
you become fully present,
that you become fully open,
and that you become empathetic.
We know that listening in
one-on-one conversations
is foundational.
And in our book, we also
explain how you can use
the power of listening to
build an extraordinary team
and a great organizational culture,
heart and centered on compassion.
- As mentioned, this is
the seventh of seven videos
in this series on positive
communication for leaders.
Feel free to look at the entire series.
We'll put links to the whole thing
in the description below the video,
as well as links to the book on Amazon,
and that free mini email class.
And if you've watched this whole series,
I just want to encourage you
to leave a comment below.
Tell us you've watched the entire series,
and I'll be sure to heart your response,
and also respond to what you have written.
And I just want to say thank you
for hanging in there with us.
This is Alex the Lion and
the original King Julien
signing off for this series.
Until next time, thanks.
God bless, and we will see you soon.